please welcome to the stage Shuhei
Yoshida
hi everyone a new dimension of gaming is
almost here and PlayStation is at the
forefront of bringing virtual reality to
gaming PlayStation VR transports you
from your living room to fascinating
world words that you'd otherwise never
have the opportunity to visit with the
strong sense of presence that
PlayStation VR creates your body
believes you are in a different world
even though your mind knows you are
wearing a VR headset and when people try
they have an outstanding experience this
week at Paris we are excited to have
eight games playable on the shop floor
games including the London heist
trailing vr rigs and battlezone just to
mention a few
we believe that virtual reality doesn't
have to be a solo experience he has
unlimited potential for social and
competitive interaction in VR one
example of this vision is rigs
mechanized combat league developed by
Guerrilla Games Cambridge rigs explores
multiplayer eSports immersed in
PlayStation VR
all hands on the trigger all eyes on the
gun you don't believe that we're strong
enough to hold on cuz I'm the only ones
again
the only ones
and we're under two minutes here and
divided Killswitch now making his move
in overdrive he leaves scores
the Cooper's take a 2-1 lead and the
crowd goes wild
combat centered around the goal another
takedown the Cobras are dominating the
game on board with crowd control she's
dangerously out of position shot from
behind he won't make that mistake again
back with anger management and overdrive
scoring opportunity where's the defense
easy
game tied 30 seconds on the clock the
covers are about to score can they do it
crowd control trying to stop him she
takes him out anyway the dynamos are
running out of time it could really use
a score here takedown she's heading for
the goal only seconds left on the clock
misses for the win
kennel
thank you
today it's my pleasure to announce a new
title in development for PlayStation VR
until dawn Russia Brad thank you with
until dawn Russia blab supermassive
games are bringing another unique horror
experience built from the ground up
exclusively to PlayStation VR a roller
coaster with a twist where the three of
the right won't just come from the truck
ahead but from a terrifying world that
is out to get you
and in addition to our first party
studios our partners are also extremely
enthusiastic about PlayStation VR and
today it's my pleasure to introduce to
the stage from Crytek Shevat Yuri
hi everybody I'm delighted to be here
today the most of us here today start
playing games the sort of we are
experienced in our homes was a distant
dream today it's a reality that just
around the corner the first time I tried
out the PlayStation VR it blew my mind
not just because I imagined what
everything we would create in it but
also the future but also because it
reminded me of the past it was like the
magical feeling of going to the movies
for the very first time or like it must
have been when people went from black
and white to color to me that's what
makes BR so special it has the power to
amaze us all over again as developers VR
allows us to explore entirely new ways
of telling stories and for players it
will let them step into worlds that are
truly without any boundaries games that
are built from ground up for VR will
capture our imaginations like never
before and the more powerful the
technology behind them the more
captivating this will be today I'm very
excited to announce that the power of
CryEngine VR and PlayStation 4 VR and
the innovative PlayStation will come
together in a brand new virtual reality
game we believe it will bring the magic
of be our home in a spectacular style
and we are very excited to give you the
very world's first look at it today from
Troy tech for PlayStation VR this is
Robinson the journey thank you
Robin your friend has led us into a bit
of a situation are you ready to play a
little game okay
the name of the game is let's not get
squashed two simple rules follow me
closely and do as I say
now the game begins
stop
Robin are you ready for a different game
achieved with CryEngine
battlezone from rebellion will be coming
first on PlayStation VR physician vr
transports you into exotic wars with
through 360 degree margin look up down
and around to capture every detail of
revolt you choose to visit and this is
not only for games but for a wide
variety of completely new experiences
take a look at the demonstration from
our sister company Sony Pictures
Entertainment people ask me why do you
risk death
for me
this is like
know it stuffs oh my god
as of today over 200 developers are
working on PlayStation VR please enjoy a
glimpse of some of the fantastic content
thank you